like a
slurpy mess of
black
[Music]
can i have a word with your uh big
brother is he here or not he's
unfortunately not he will be here for
dinner service tonight okay all right
enjoy thank you
okay
oh
that that is hideous it's hot in parts
like in the middle but on the side
there's stone cold
[Music]
you want me to take it is the oven not
working no the oven's working fine you
can't circle this [ __ ] and expect
customers to float through the door i
understand how long has he been here the
martine
too long you're not wrong there
martine lost his mojo around here many
years ago if you got someone who doesn't
care about the food they're putting out
what do you have
martine he said it's hot in the middle
it's cold on the sides he doesn't like
it
thank you
oh [ __ ] how long has that been under the
grill because it looks like it's been
overcooked it's piping hot is he
microwaving that i don't know girl yes
when normally something's that piping
hot like that it always tells you that
it's been microwaved can you just check
with a chef okay i'll check listen thank
you
okay martine
the quiche is warmed in the oven yeah
hasn't seen the microwave
nope
[Music]
no microwave
i asked him if he put it in he said no
hold on
i'm convinced this has been microwaved
look at it it's congealed it's just like
a rubber puck
sometimes if he gets a little backed up
i i've seen him do it before backed up
this is ridiculous
and let's go and meet martine please
it's a food issue right now that starts
from the kitchen if we had somebody in
here who cared about the food we'd be so
much better than we are now
martin i want you to meet jeff ramsey
come on
you're the head chef
and everything i ate
for lunch you cooked yes sir
lunch was a disaster
the kitchen was
rancid
where did you heat that up was that in
the microwave oven
no i disagree okay
we sat on the microwave and then uh
we're on the oven yes so it did go in
the microwave that is right yes but you
just told me it wasn't in the microwave
why'd you want to lie to me i don't you
want me to lie to you i'm not lying to
you i'm just telling you how do i do it
i'm i'm so amazed that you're so laid
back and like you don't give a [ __ ]
talk to me what do you want me to say
why don't you care is it because you
hate celine
what does that have to do with cookies
her because she said to me in the time
every time she tries to tell you
something
bang no she jump down here she will come
and attack me
yes sir like saying that i'm in here for
too long it's time for me to go if
you're not prepared to change yeah i
think she's right
if it is time for me to go i go
that was easy martin
lam shank
[Music]
now there's a very anemic looking lamp
shank look at the presentation it's
depressing almost like it's been in the
microwave for an hour i'm sure they
wouldn't microwave them shank i'm a
little bit nervous to have gray the meat
is
it's way too salty and badly balanced
justin i mean so salty who cooked that
dustin that's chef mike
chef who chef mike
it's a microwave
i thought it was the third chef
he kind is he does a lot of work in the
kitchen huh we use chef mike a lot
whenever there's lights on in this
restaurant chef mike's working he's a
dedicated employee
he uh asked about chef mike he said he
has to have cooked it i mean i can't lie
to him
so i told him
he's not happy holy [ __ ] dude
i can't take those [ __ ]
hello
hi
i am kiki
yeah how are you nice to see you
nothing is good may i finish my lunch
first and then have a chat
no english no okay i'm sorry scottish
french
spanish
germany
okay
i don't speak german but it's good to
know thank you thank you
this is the one i'm gonna serve
conservative man go god it's so
embarrassing i don't care at this point
i don't give a [ __ ] about anything
[Music]
now you think of greece you think of
authenticity
that
is not authentic it's a non-moving
osaka what a disaster
he went like this stayed on there
jacob's i don't care
if you saw his food in a dog food bowl
you would not think twice
osaka what was that
what does that mean i'm not sure uh
you don't like it the eggplant or
anything did chef mike have a hand in
this one
chef mike has a hand in a lot of dishes
wow
yeah how'd you like try anything else no
it's just too painful it's not possible
for a restaurant to be so are you eating
them they're microwavable microwaving
them
it's disgusting
for god's sake
is there anything today that i ate that
wasn't microwaved excellent
the sellers
you [ __ ] donut of course you don't
put a [ __ ] stuff
guys i'm not laughing i'm so
disappointed
oh sorry um i i think i'd like to have
it just a little bit more done a little
more
yeah
what's the matter
a little more a little bit what's wrong
on it cold in the middle
okay put in the microwave
let's put a microwave put it in a minute
and a half
double rock
go back right now
[Music]
i kind of got the idea that maybe
someone just took this plate because the
plate's pretty warm and maybe just stuck
back into the microwave instead of
putting the lamb chops back into a pan
yes thank you
[Music]
[ __ ] busting my ball now wait let me
see now it's too much cooking for it's
too [ __ ] rare and now it's too much
how do they want the meat the first time
oh my god how did they want to cook
salmon i don't know i'm gonna [ __ ]
ask the lady you know
with food now coming back it's a perfect
opportunity for gordon to witness
sammy's customer service skills how did
you want your nico
would you want a rear and you want
something medium so can we make you
another one will you wait or you don't
want it at all wait but the thing is is
i don't want you to stick it back in a
microwave no we're gonna throw that on
make your new one nobody's talking about
microwave you're the ones talking about
microwave they came out of a microwave
otherwise they won't be like exuding do
you work for a microwave company you
know so much about microwave
[Music]
unbelievable
unbelievable
[ __ ] out of here let's take a hike
[ __ ] told me went to a microwave
i'm gonna make fun of let her wait let
her wait now i don't know if this lady
wanted a free meal or whatever i thought
it was a total nightmare i kept my
composure i wanted to kill her and i
didn't jose it's not your fault the lamb
is tough
if you even [ __ ] tools to work with of
course you're going to create [ __ ] food
here's the landmarker
bring it to come
[Music]
on no wait wait we're not done yet i
want to see you cut into it
how is it is it still too rare you know
what i'm done no more chances
unbelievable
oh my god i just wanted to pick her up
and throw her out there's a right way
and a wrong way of handling something
like that and she was totally wrong this
is chef mike you've been so busy
it's time that you took a little
vacation
what's going on i don't know
hey guys
i've got something to uh to show you
what are you doing
[Music]
it's time to say goodbye
to a very busy
chef mike jeff mike guys dad
yes
[Music]